et il y a des complications habituelles
de la chirurgie comme à descrim Madame
il y a toujours des risques d'infection
il y a des risques d'asymétrie il y a
des risques d'hématomes et il y a aussi
des risques vitaux on s'était dit que
le lipo feeling des fesses c'est pas un
soin du corps c'est une intervention
qu'il faut prendre avec beaucoup de
sérieux et il faut bien y réfléchir
avant de la faire ça demande de la
maturité ça demande de la réflexion
avant une intervention et il faut
sûrement pas le faire juste pour céder à
un caprice maintenant de quoi on meurt
dans un injection de graisse dans les
fesses essentiellement d'une embolie
graisseuse c'est-à-dire que si on
injecte de la graisse dans un gros
vaisseau dans le muscle et bien la
graisse peut aller dans la circulation
générale boucher le poumon et on peut en
mourir d'ailleurs il faut savoir que
cette intervention est interdite en
Angleterre donc ça donne quand même le
niveau et quand je vous disais que tout
à l'heure en France c'est pas très
pratiqué parce qu'on est quand même très
au courant des risques et de l'intérêt
relatif
25 personnes sont mortes en Floride à la
suite on intervention de bbl en cause
souvent des chirurgiens verrues qui
prennent beaucoup moins cher mais qui ne
respectent pas toutes les règles
regardez
en disant 25 patients de son mort ton
Floride à la suite d'une opération de
bbmrania avait 33 ans et vivait au Texas
pour l'opération comme beaucoup d'autres
américaines elle choisit un médecin basé
à Miami opération BBL tout compris dans
une clinique qui propose des prix 35%
moins cher que celle de Viviana elle
était en blouse d'hôpital elle lui a
montré la pièce où elle se trouvait et
ça n'avait pas l'air d'être stérilisé ça
ne ressemblait pas du tout à un hôpital
mais au bout d'une heure
serait retrouvé en arrêt cardiaque le
médecin aurait la serré son foie pendant
la liposuccion
docteur Cyril évoquait la dangerosité
j'ai lu un mort pour 3000 interventions
ce qui est un taux incroyable j'ai vu ça
dans une revue scientifique je sais pas
si vous confirmez ma question elle est
simple pourquoi est-ce qu'on interdit
pas cette opération si dangereuse c'est
ce que je dis effectivement c'est c'est
une intervention il faut toujours
calculer le bénéfice risque et moi je
trouve que cette intervention elle est
extrêmement risquée les Anglais ils
seront pas plus bêtes que nous et si
l'ont interdit c'est que réellement le
danger existe bien sûr faites dans des
conditions strictes de chirurgie dans un
vrai bloc opératoire pas dans une
arrière cuisine avec un anesthésiste
réanimateur de qualité avec de quoi
assumer n'importe quelle complication
c'est une intervention que l'on peut
faire qui est faite mais aucune
intervention n’est sans risque et donc
c'est là est particulièrement
problématique